tennis star naomi osaka has withdrawn
from the french open
organizers threatened to expel her when
she boycotted a news conference
the world number two decided not to face
reporters after her first round win over
patricia tigg
citing mental health issues she was
fined
fifteen thousand dollars now osaka had
said she would not attend the obligatory
news conferences
she says facing the media affects her
mental well-being
let's bring in chris harrington from dw
sports now hi chris
what more can you tell us about naomi
osaka's departure from this tournament
well you know she went into a little
more details on social media and it came
you know
it surprised me that since 2018 that's
when she won her first grand slam
that's when her depression started and
since then she's been dealing with that
a lot of social anxiety as well
typically you see her wearing headphones
and then she explained why she does that
so she can kind of dull out you know the
crowd and other things like this
and you know just her actions are a
strong reminder to all of us that
we're all human no matter our position
or no matter our ability
and you know i think it took uh quite a
bit of courage for her to do
what she did well it is raising a lot of
questions about whether the mental
health of athletes is being taken
seriously i mean
is it well let me just highlight a few
issues a few athletes that have had
shared that they've had mental uh issues
michael phelps a known swimmer
you know he's dealt with anxiety in the
past he associated those issues to his
dui
problems driving under the influence uh
and here in germany
robert inca was a german footballer who
committed suicide in 2009
he was suffering with depression as well
due to the death of his daughter now
fast forward to now
i could argue the french tennis
federation has not done enough because
they basically put her in a difficult
situation
they find her she expresses why you know
maybe she doesn't want to speak to the
media
and they say that okay you're going to
have to either accept your anxiety
or be fined i think that's unfair and
hopefully it'll raise awareness to
the organizations and people a lot of
her naysayers as well that
this is a serious issue that needs the
attention it deserves
what kind of support is naomi osaka
getting from fellow athletes
well courage is the common thread among
support we've seen support outside of
the sport of tennis but i'll highlight
serena williams serena williams is the
her opponent who she defeated to win her
first grand slam
williams was very supportive of osaka
she said she wanted to give her a hug
and this is
what else she had to say we have
different personalities
um and people are different not everyone
is the same
um i'm thick you know other people are
thin
so everyone is different
and everyone handles things differently
so
you know you just have to let her handle
it the way she wants to in the best way
that she thinks she can
and that's the only thing i can say i
think she's
doing the best that she can
so words of support there from serena
williams what is next for naomi osaka
osaka japanese american she's expected
to be one of the major attractions at
tokyo 2020.
you know she talked about that she
doesn't want to rest she wants to go
after the next major tournament
you know so i do wish her well then all
of the support and i'm sure she's tuning
in to all of
the support she's already received chris
harrington from dw sports thank you so
much for bringing us that story
thank you